A very warm welcome. Super excited to invite you into this training to welcome you to this
training where you're going to be learning a tremendous amount of very interesting things
that are going to empower your personal life and your working life. Whether you're part
of our association or companies, going through this training is going to enrich you in so
many ways. It's going to help you be mentally stronger, drawing on all of the work that
I've done with professional athletes around the world, leaders. I'm going to be sharing
with you so many interesting secrets and insights that's going to definitely strengthen your
mindset as well as your emotional intelligence, your emotional fitness, however you like to
think of it. A whole bunch of other things are going to be involved in this training.
It's going to ultimately enrich or give you personal power or more capacity to do your
work better, to be more attractive in your personal life, what I mean by attractive.
I mean understanding people better, understanding yourself better. This makes your communication
so much more enjoyable for those around you and of course for yourself. So there's so
many exciting benefits that are going to be coming up for this course. You're going to
be going through different levels, different stages and as you go through these stages
you're going to unlock different types of trainings that are going to help you see things
in different ways and ultimately that's going to help you grow as a human being. Part of
our culture in both our association and our companies is we love to grow. We think of
ourselves as lifelong learners. So I want to be an old man and learning things and growing
and being curious because part of going through this training and getting a lot of benefit
from it is that you come in curious, you come in with a desire to learn and grow as a human
being and that takes a measure of humility but also a measure of how would I put it?
Yeah, just a willingness to open yourself to grow in life. A lot of times people are
very close minded, they're set and rigid in their ways and that really stagnates them.
It's like a body of water in nature. When you look at nature and you see a body of water
that's moving as in it's flowing there's life, there's vitality and you can drink from that
water and be nourished as opposed to a body of water that's stagnant. It's not moving
anymore and in that body of water you can't really nourish yourself or drink from it.
In fact if you drink from that you can even get contaminated or ill. Now a lot of people
are like that. They're stagnant and they're set and they're fixed and they're not growing,
they're not flowing, they're not moving and we don't want to be those types of people.
We want to be individuals, people that provide life for those around us, that provide nourishment
that we get to grow and it's one of the core human needs which you can look at as you go
through this. There's six core needs that we'll eventually explore at some stage in
these modules and one of those human needs that we all share is a need to grow and that's
what this training is going to be able to give you. You're going to be able to process
this training in your own unique way. You're going to be able to explore it and map it
back to your own life or reflect back on your own life and it's going to help you see things
about your personal life, it's going to help you see things about your past, about your
current reality or life and that's ultimately going to give you more power and if you don't
like the word power perhaps think of it as more options and when I say if you don't like
the word power part of what we're also going to explore is how different words have different
meanings for each of us and that's part of the way in which we interpret our world around
us and it's going to be really fun to explore that. So I'm really excited to go on this
journey with you. I love helping people develop and grow. That's one of my gifts or one of
my passions and I've been helping a whole bunch of people from professional athletes
on the biggest stages in the world where they were climbing over to those big tournaments
like the US Open Stray and Open and I would help them with their anxiety, their confidence
or help the teams and the coaches communicate with their athletes right through business
leaders who are presenting on world stages speaking in front of large amounts of people,
helping them grow as individuals and also working with companies and leaders at different
levels. So I love seeing people shine. I love seeing people grow. I love seeing people
blossom and just like we enjoy watching beautiful flowers or nature blossom around us, that's
something that I really enjoy. So I'm excited for you. I'm excited for this adventure that
you're going to go on as you work through these levels and modules. Enjoy the journey,
enjoy the process. There's going to be times where you're going to be challenged. There's
going to be times where the light bulb is going to go off and you're going to realize
things that you haven't seen before and ultimately it's going to be a fun adventure. So enjoy
and I'll see you in the next section.